Well, being a conductor means the electrons are free to move, not protons.
Protons like I said before are really quite big. Electrons are tiny.
Electrons are easy to move around. So positive charges aren't going to do any flowing.
But what will happen is some electrons will flow from A to B.
Remember, electrons have a negative charge
and they'll do that because this positive charge is attracting them.
And that is our second method of charging. Charging by conduction.
It's when you touch a charged object to an uncharged object,
and the uncharged object becomes charged.
There's one more very clever method of charging an object that involves polarization.